the 90s we had turtle power
we had acto cooler and we had some of
the very worst comic books ever printed
and sold for actual money or at least
that's how many comic book fans have
chosen to remember the decade me I do
what I can to put this assertion to the
test right here on 90s comics free trial
where I go through my own personal
collection of comic books stuff that I
own that is taking up space in my house
that I acquired mostly between 1992 and
1996 I go through these things with
fresh eyes and try to see if the decade
is in fact as bad as this reputation
now this marks the video debut of what
had once upon a time been the primary
podcast feature of the council of geeks
podcast feed I've been thinking for some
time about trying this out in a video
format especially because I spend a lot
more time on YouTube than I do
podcasting and I really went back and
forth on what comic to start with
initially I was gonna do a video version
of my recently wrapped up coverage of
executioner's song um which was how that
podcast ended because that proved to be
biting off more than I could chew and
honestly covering that thing kind of
broke me I have since decided that at
least for the time being I don't want to
talk about issues or stories that I
already covered in podcast form thus I
dug through my pile of nineties comics
from image because nobody was more 90s
than image and pulled out the first
cyber force annual now this being my
first attempt at video format I'm going
to end up inevitably taking a few cues
from the comic book reviews of Linkara
however I'm going to try really hard to
not just rip them off wholesale so let's
dig into cyber force annual number one
and see how this particular preserved
piece of 90's xtreme holds up 25 years
later
[Music]
something you'll probably pick up right
away into this and I should be upfront
about I don't really do research
it makes me break out in a rash so don't
expect it ton of background or context
or information or other stories with
these characters stuff about the
creators the approach of this is to
revisit these comics the same way I read
them when I first bought them with
whatever working knowledge I already had
and sometimes that's a fair bit
sometimes that is next to nothing in
this case it was kind of in the middle I
know that cyber force was created by
Marc Silvestri and was one of the big
teams of the Marvel image titles along
with Youngblood Brigade there were a few
others but those are the ones off ahead
there are almost I well this group
anyway is pretty much the most blatant
x-men ripoff that the company was doing
and most of these were x-men ripoffs it
was actually a little bit surprising
coming from Silvestri given that he had
worked on uncanny x-men over a Marvel
before he and the other founders of
image split off to form that company
you'd think he know better than to
ripoff what he was previously just
working on but even you know for being a
ripoff it is not subtle about its
influence you know it deals with people
who have innate abilities there are
numerous characters who are practically
one-to-one analogues right back to
specific x-men rip claws Wolverine
strikers cable impact his colossus sigh
blade a psylocke etc etc there are
tweaks here and there a few mashups
velocity is Kitty Pryde with
quicksilver's power set but I mean the
templates are painfully obvious and the
difference in terms of the pitch is just
is that these aren't only mutants they
were also experimented on having been
cybernetically modified by and are now
fighting against the machinations of the
shadowy cyber Data Corporation and I
might end up saying cyber data so
forgive me basically what they did was
they applied
Wolverines Weapon X backstory do every
single member of the team
and as a kid around the age of 11 I
thought this was the coolest thing ever
we'll see if that remains the case so
cyber force annual number one has a
cover date of March 1995 it was plotted
by Marc Silvestri and Mike Heisler with
the latter also on scripting duties
David Finch was the penciler nathan
cabrera
was on inks there was a whole team of
folks on coloring duties with David wool
handling the lettering so that's credits
all the way let's start with the cover
and broadly speaking it's pretty solid
in concept image was always really big
on covers where the hero or team of
heroes are just kind of posed there but
there's a lot more sense of story than
usual in this particular cover from you
know versus other image stuff at the
time we've got a graveyard at dusk you
know it's it's got former villain
ballistic holding the possibly dead body
of you're her younger sister velocity
and shadowed in the background we have
most of the remaining members of cyber
force from left to right in case you
happen to be wondering we have rip claw
heatwave
Dominique with impact behind her and
then Stryker on the far right all well
and good as a concept and a general
composition so it really does break my
heart that the details completely let
this down firstly of the six people not
of you know possibly dead five of them
are going for stone-faced stoicism
Dominique is uh has a little bit more of
a motion in her pose and expression but
honestly it's so low-key I could just as
easily believe that she's got an upset
stomach from eating Chipotle this is
most evident on the face of ballistic
who just has no expression at all I'm
pretty sure those are meant to be tears
over on her left eye but they look more
like prison tattoos they really needed a
streaking tear down the cheek if that's
what they were trying to go for or
would that not have been badass enough
hell the person with the most expression
is the one who might be dead but let's
get off faces and talk about where the
real effort appears to have been put
when it comes to the the work on this
cover huh it's the boobs
holy cleavage Batman I'm not sure how
long I can linger on these shots without
getting flagged for inappropriate
content but notice how much tension
there is in ballistics neck what is
going on there looks like she's
straining her neck just to be sure her
head isn't even slightly blocking the
view of her rack aah
then there's velocity with her bodysuit
so tight she might as well just be naked
anyways inside it opens with velocity
setting up a training exercise for
herself and it's totally different from
the Danger Room in x-men because it's in
the woods and not actually in a room
it's the danger field out of boredom she
ups the difficulty level from two to
five and is immediately beset upon by
big vicious robots I just want to ask I
just a trainee why does she have
clearance to up the danger level that
high like on Star Trek with the holodeck
only the highest-ranking officers could
disable the safety protocols on the
holodeck because you don't give that
kind of authority to someone who has a
proven themselves to be responsible and
with that Star Trek comparison I think I
just invited even more accusations of
ripping off Linkara because he's kind of
big into Star Trek so I I'd better move
on from that so inevitably velocity gets
in over her head but the exercise is
terminated by the Android Timmy whose
name is in fact an anagram for totally
independent mobile machine intelligence
experiment since nobody asked
velocity expresses her frustration
partly summing from just wanting to
improve faster and partly due to the
fact that cyber data locked her memories
she basically guilts Timmy into brain
scanning her which naturally goes even
more wrong than the training exercise
did this is the point where we start
getting flashbacks to velocities
childhood in black and white with a few
pops of colors on things like velocities
hair which yeah I'll be honest it's a
nice touch and presumably she's
experiencing these flashbacks as the
reader is but in the real world
she's totally non-responsive and the
rest of the group having been called in
by Timmy fears that they tripped some
kind of defense function in the brain
box that cyber data had implanted the
cyber force team determines that the
only way that they're gonna save
velocity is to take her to a cyber data
for facility my god facility I know
words and hope that the source of the
problem might have a means to in fact
correct it meanwhile velocities memories
have taken a nasty turn after starting
with her playing with her family and her
sister we now get treated to a broken
home where her father's left and the man
who's taken his place is pretty much a
walking wife beater stereotype like
complete with tank top beer in hand
Cassie velocities older sister who later
becomes ballistic tries to confront the
man and velocity runs off to get help
from the first cop she can find
and when I say runs off I mean she
really runs did this isn't quite the
thing where their powers developed later
now the cop arrives to find the man dead
with a comb having been thrown by Cassie
so hard that it impaled him in the chest
that's for Weiss face is bloody though
the flashback jumps ahead a bit velocity
is now being shown at the sunshine
orphanage where apparently preteens not
only have access to tattoo guns but
they're able to ink a perfect lightning
bolt on the face of ace
struggling super-fast child following
the tattoo session velocity and her
tormentor are informed by the mutant
mother mae-eye that they will be going
with these very nice men in black suits
now and they're both promptly thrown in
the back of a van by what I'm gonna
presume our cyber data operatives now
coming back to the real world we jumped
to queens where a guy in a very cheap
looking suit jacket is hitting on a
blonde at a bar that is until the
cybernetic arm of Stryker grabs him and
tells him to beat it
I do actually know this from other
issues this is a bit of a running joke
because this guy keeps trying to hit on
ballistic in this specific bar and being
scared off or shoot away by Stryker or
other mutants so I guess it's funny if
you've been keeping track I thought it
was funny at the time anyways Stryker
fills her in on what's been going on and
she joins the team in transporting
velocity to cyber data more flashbacks
bit of a life in cyber data training
montage and in real time ballistic gets
to work on breaking the team in to cyber
data blasting away century who I
honestly couldn't figure out if it was
meant to be a robot or a human in armor
it like the speech bubble says robot but
it has like a AK response which to me
says human whatever they break in they
run into more maybe robot guards
fighting happens and then velocity is
hooked up to the technobabble machine
and cyber data sends its heavy hitters
now before I want you know to get into
any more I need to talk about one of
these characters the character of
killjoy
now I encountered this character in
cyber forestation number two and I
immediately fell in love with her
character wise she's got a bit of a
Starscream thing going on appearing to
have criticism toward the team leader
which at the time I read that issue was
ballistic and possibly even plans to
undermine her outright
now the thing is unlike Starscream
killjoy is both way more subtle about
what she's up to
and also really competent at her role in
the team proves her value handily and
repeatedly but what I really loved about
her was how unsexual eyes she looked my
first time reading sniper force number
two I actually didn't even realize the
killjoy was a woman I'm serious it went
completely over my head I didn't pick up
on it until subsequent rereads of that
issue there's a couple reasons for this
partly it's the costume design partly
it's how live her overall proportions
are but mostly it's the fact that she
isn't posed in a manner that screams
check it out this chick there's really
only one image of her in that issue
where there's even the slightest hint of
a bust and she doesn't have crazy hips
either I thought she was maybe a slender
ninja type guy and what I actually
realized that she was a woman it blew my
young mind I imagine it was similar to
like the first time that players beat
the original Metroid and suddenly
realized that Samus was a woman like wow
this insane kpop person is a woman oh
cool now having said all that in this
issue
this is how they depict her what and the
cavernous depths of hell's navel is this
I honestly I can't even break this now
just look at it look at it everybody who
was involved with this who knew that the
character was gonna be drawn in this
issue like this and failed to speak up
and stop what was happening needs to be
very ashamed of themselves like yes even
23 years later they should still be
ashamed as for me I I gotta move on so
anyway she shows up with some of her
less interesting cronies like megawatt
Hotspur buzzcut and
the other one never got we got more
fighting it lasts a little bit longer
than with the guards since it's supposed
to be you know like the spare the scary
bad guys fight I reminded once again of
what a blatant x-men ripoff this is as
the villain Hotspur takes on sci bleed
who has the power of psionic blades and
looks like this this this is beyond
shameless anyways Hotspur gets taken
down from behind by heatwave and
possibly even straight-up killed
judging by the art before facing off
against psycho truck right that was the
other one's name okay no wonder I
couldn't remember jeez anyway more
characters face off but we actually
don't see much of it because the bigger
issue is killjoy breezing her way past
rip claw and getting ready to completely
wipe Velocity's brain but killjoy ends
up taking a few bullets dude a ballistic
showing up and she calls a retreat as a
result oh I guess Hotspur isn't dead you
know I honestly don't know why the
heroes are letting them walk away I I
can't remember if cyber force had a
no-kill rule or not but they didn't
really seem like the type they use an
awful lot of guns to be nonviolent
anyway velocity comes to she and her
sister embrace and the to reaffirm their
love for each other so that wraps up
cyber force annual number one which now
leaves me to render a verdict on this
thing ultimately what I'm usually
looking for are particularly egregious
examples of 90s XS in terms of story
characters and especially the art but it
does have to be true excess or true
failures like the simple presence of
nineties ness is not enough to condemn a
comic that just makes a product of its
time now back when this was a podcast
I'll point out that the previous issue
of cyber force that I covered number two
which I talked about a little bit that
did end up getting convicted but my
heart wasn't really in that verdict
because as silly as the thing was
rereading it I couldn't help but
remember how this art these characters
the situation I just drawn me in and
made me want more what ultimately
condemned that issue was just how
disjointed it was because it felt like
the end of the previous issue and the
start of the next one were crammed
together but they didn't bother to
actually like flow from one to the next
and neither half felt like a complete
story in and of itself it was two half
stories that barely related and that's
ultimately what sunk that but that's not
a play with this issue this is a
complete story so should mean all things
are all good right well not so fast
because cyber force number two had
killjoy she was meant to be and not
whatever the heck this is supposed to be
and also all these characters have
always been blatant x-men ripoffs it
feels way more blatant and shameless
here than it did in that other issue and
plus some others that I have liked
between the characters in which I
pointed out some of the one two ones and
finally getting a good look at mother
mae-eye who's the character I seen
referenced before but hadn't actually
seen in art and ends up just being a
ripoff of mystique I know in this she's
in black and white she's actually blue
there's the danger I'm except it's
outdoors I mean like all of this adds up
to this whole concept feeling way more
derivative than it ever did before
now as far as annuals go and the type of
stories that go on and look it's not bad
it's a complete story fills in some
background for anybody who cares and but
it also doesn't feel like folks who
would skip this and stick only to the
main series would be missing out on
anything super vital and wouldn't be
able to keep up with the story but in
the end it's just not enough to overcome
the other problems here the big one just
being how generic this all feels I will
maintain that as far as image teams of
the 90s went you know Youngblood Brigade
cyber force was about as good as it got
in those early days but it was still
image in the 90s and it's kind of rare
for that to skate by so cyber force
annual number one is going to be
couldn't
acted of 90s era awfulness for it's
functional but wrote plot fight scenes
that never feel like we get to see all
of them
and you know just the vandalism of what
happens to killjoy so there we go folks
that's it for this cyber force annual
number one convicted of 90s era
awfulness again not thrilled about that
because I do like this title but yeah
this this is not a particularly good
piece of work not the harshest
conviction I've ever laid down or will
ever lay down in the future I'm sure but
it's a conviction nonetheless so that
wraps up the inaugural video debut of
90's comics retrial if you have enjoyed
this I would recommend that you check
out the council geese podcast feed where
the old stuff is up if you want to give
it a listen and depending on how well
this does it might become a monthly
feature that was probably pushing it
because honestly this took me a lot
longer to do then I was expecting it to
but you know if it's particularly
popular maybe I'll probably start
throwing it out to my patreon supporters
some options of what comic book issues
to cover for future ones which I suppose
serves as a segue for me to plug the
patreon so check that out if you want
links down below plus other buttons and
stuff and links things to check out give
it a look if you feel like it but if you
don't that is okay support is
appreciated but not required because at
the end of the day folks if you're
watching this you are the council and
indeed quite possibly in this case the
jury
I'm just running the meetings or maybe
just delivering the verdicts but in any
case until next time this Court is
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]